THE SENATE IS READY TO GET BACK
TO WORK.
JUDGE JEANINE: WELCOME BACK TO
WORK.
BREAK OUR DEPENDENCE ON CHINA
AND HOLDING THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR
MISHANDLING AND DECEPTION DURING
THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS THAT AND
MORE, THE RELATIONSHIP CAN
SENATOR FROM THE GREAT STATE OF
TEXAS.
GOOD EVENING, SENATOR.
IT’S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT IN
ADDITION TO SEVERAL BILLS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN PROPOSED IN
CONGRESS, THAT YOU ARE COMING AT
THIS DEALING WITH CHINA FROM A
LOT OF DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS.
YOU HAVE SEVERAL BILLS YOU ARE
ABOUT TO SUBMIT TUESDAY IN
CONGRESS.
TELL US WHERE YOU ARE COMING
FROM AND WHAT YOU ARE DEALING
WITH.
>> WELL, ABSOLUTELY.
CHINA IS IN MY JUDGMENT THE
SINGLE GREATEST GEOPOLITICAL
THREAT THE UNITED STATES FACES
OVER THE NEXT CENTURY.
THEY ENGAGE IN IS ANY NAWJ, THEY
ENGAGE IN CENSORSHIP, THEY
ENGAGE IN TORTURE AND MURDER OF
THEIR OWN CITIZENS.
THEY COVER UP FREE SPEECH.
I HAVE GOT THREE BILLS I’M
INTRODUCTION THIS COMING WEEK.
ONE IS FOCUSED ON THE
CORONAVIRUS COVER-UP.
IT IMPOSES STRICT SANCTIONS ON
CHINESE OFFICIALS WHO COVERED UP
THIS PANDEMIC.
THEY ARE DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE PANDEMIC THAT KILLED
OVER 240,000 PEOPLE WORLDWIDE.
THE WHISTLEBLOWER, THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT CAME DOWN ON THEM,
SILENCED THEM.
WE USED TO THINK OF THEIR
SUPPRESSION OF SPEECH AS A HUMAN
RIGHTS ISSUE IT’S CLEAR TO
EVERYONE THIS IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUE.
WHEN IT COMES TO PROPAGANDA, I’M
INTRODUCING LEGISLATION THAT’S
CALLED THE SCRIPT ACT THAT IS
FOCUSED ON HOLLYWOOD.
HOLLYWOOD FAR TOO OFTEN LETS THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT CENSOR THEIR
CAN FILLS.
THE SCRIPTS ACT SAYS WE WON’T
COOPERATE WITH HOLLYWOOD AND LET
THEM USE SHIPS AND PLANES AND
EQUIPMENT IF THEY ARE GOING TO
ALLOW THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO
CENSOR.
IT’S THE POWER OF THE ARERR --
IT’S THE POWER OF GOVERNMENT TO
STOP CENSORSHIP THROUGH
HOLLYWOOD.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHEN THE MOVIES
ARE MADE, THE PENTAGON ASSISTS
BY ALLOWING THEM TO USE THEIR
EQUIPMENT?
>> THERE ARE OVER A THOUSAND
MOVIES.
A MOVIE COMING OUT LATER THIS
YEAR, THE SEQUEL TO TOP GUN.
IT MAY HAVE ENDED UP BEING THE
GREATEST NAVY RECRUITING FILM
EVER FILMED.
YOU HAVE GOT MAVERICK FLYING A
JET.
YOUNG BOYS AND GIRLS WANTED TO
BE FIGHTER PILOTS.
THE NEW TOP GUN 2, THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT TOOK ISSUE WITH THE
FACT THAT MAVERICK’S JACKET HAD
A JAPANESE ANTIJUAN AND -- AND A
FLAG.
WE ARE SAYING MAVERICK IS
SCARED OF THE CHINESE
COMMUNISTS.
THAT’S RIDICULOUS.
HOLLYWOOD PRODUCER WHO CLAIM TO
SUPPORT THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND
FREE SPEECH READILY LET THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT CENSOR.
THE MOVIE BOHEMIAN RHAPSODY.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT CENSORS
OBJECTED TO A SCENE IN THE MOVIE
THAT ACKNOWLEDGED THAT FRED
YESTERDAY MURPHY WAS GAY.
SO THEY EDITED THE SCENE OUT OF
THE MOVIE.
HOW ON EARTH THE TO YOU TELL THE
STORY OF EDDIE HER MERCURY WITHO
ACKNOWLEDGING HE WAS GAY?
HOLLYWOOD DOES THIS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THE GOVERNMENT IS NOT GOING TO
FACILITATE YOUR EMPOWERING THE
CHINESE CENSORS.
JUDGE JEANINE: HOLLYWOOD IS SO
WILLING TO DO THAT FOR THE
CHINESE.
BUT FROM THE END THEY ARE
WILLING TO CRITICIZE THOSE OF US
WHO STAND UP FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT IN THIS COUNTRY.
SENATOR TED CRUZ, THANKS SO MUCH